SUNDAY, A MAKEUP GAME BETWEEN
TWO NON-PLAYOFFS.
HE'S INTO THE
THE NET.
HIS SHOTSHOT RIGHT OFF
THE CLOCK AS F CLUBS THERE
TONIGHT.
SIX OF THE EIGHT PLAYOFF
MATCHUPS ARE NOTEY TRIED TO CEN
THINK AT THE LOT.
LAST SECOND EFFORT THERESHABBAT
LOOKING TO GET INTO
BETW FACED DOWN THERE FOR JB OF
ADVANTAGE.
HE TOOK  TAKE IT AWAY AND CLEAR
>> Steve: IT TRACKS HIM DOWN
AND THAT WOBBLING PUCK ENDS UP
ON THE STICK OF BRADY
EVENTUALLY.
HE KIND OFHS AGO YESTERDAY -- AL
PROVO LOVE TO THIS FORGIVING TH
THEY WERE BACK IN THE DAY.
BUT YOU CAN TELL THAT HE HAS
BEEN IN A LOT OFT'S
THREE MINISTRY.
ONE POINT FOR THE DEVILS IN
THAT GAME. PICK IT UP AROUND
THHEY LEFT IT DOWN THOUGH.
BACK OUT FOR HIS SHIFT AFTER
THAT COLLISION.
HE GETS IT. OWING THE
WHISTLE  WITH THREE OR FOUR
EXTRA CRACKS OUT OF THERE.
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO MANEUVER
H!
THEY ENJOYED IT.
A FACE-OFF WIN
STAYING RIGHT WITH HIM, BACK ON
CHABOT.
THE FLYERS HAVE BEEN OUT FOR A
LONG TIME.
HE SCORES!
SENATORS IN THE POWER-PLAY.
Y NET SHOT
AGAIN.
THIS TIME THEY BURY IT.
THAT